vintage Bale is known as the capital of
the
resistance it has symbolic importance to
Hezbollah much of the town was heavily
bombed during the Lebanese armed group's
last war with Israel in 2006 but its
Fighters held their
ground nearly two decades later they're
again at
War ventes B has not yet been caught in
the crossfire but the group's supporters
believe Israel wants to expand the cont
Israel doesn't hide its intentions of
course it would like to expand the
ongoing War but in the presence of
hezbollah's leader Hassan nasrah and our
resistant Fighters we are not
afraid not far is an active front line
along more than 100 km of Border a few
kilometers deep on each side the
crossborder fire is now in its second
month and Hezbollah is promising more of
this as as long as Israel continues its
war on Gaza the group's leader Hassan
Nala has talked about increasing
operations in terms of size frequency
and the type of weapons but making it
clear this border will remain what he
calls a support front for
Gaza Israel has been increasing its
threats not just against Hezbollah but
Lebanon as a whole with the defense
minister promising to do to the Lebanese
Capital Beirut what it did to Gaza the
Waring sides have been using tough
rhetoric hisbah has made it clear that
the Battleground will determine the
course of the conflict if Israel
escalates it will respond in kind if
they target civilians Hezbollah will do
the same despite the occasional strikes
that have hit deeper into each other's
territories this still largely remains a
war of attrition that could change as
Israel battles Hamas fighters in Gaza
zanak Al jaaz Southern Le
on